this is the Winchester Mystery House it
is one of the most haunted places in
America we are on the set of the
Winchester film starring Dame Helen
Mirren it's like a maze you go in one
door you come out a window and then you
walk down a set of stairs and you're a
totally different area and all you can
feel boxed right in there is the
enclosure you take one wrong turn and
you are a goner and now actually getting
taken to the Winchester rifle Museum
let's go on the grounds here we're gonna
learn more about Sarah the rifle
themselves like there's been so many
deaths by the hands of all of these guns
one of the main things that Sarah
Winchester herself believed is that she
was being haunted by the spirits if it
were booth died from the hands of this
rifle yeah I mean there's a lot of
mystery around Sarah Winchester there's
not that much that's documented
[Music]
Casey that door so if you had any super
experience you see somebody who I cannot
see hug me and start dancing with me and
this is where Clyde the boiler man loves
[Music]
table came to a rumored out floorboard
creak in without a chill coming down
your spine their hair sticking up on the
back in there you see an inch of this
house just gives you the shivers and the
shakes
[Music]
this place is a hundred percent haunted
I feel like I may be taking some type of
demon or some type of possession home
with me
[Music]